THAT WOULD NOT BE THE 99.9% OF
OUR MILITARY.
WE WILL SHOW YOU THE DISGUSTING
COVERAGE STRAIGHT AHEAD.
FIRST BIG BREAKING NEWS,
JOE BIDEN HAS FINALLY EMERGED
FROM HIS BASEMENT.
WELL SORT OF END VERY QUICKLY
AND WRITE BACK TO HIS BASEMENT,
MONDAY AFTER TWO ALONG MONTHS IN
HIDING HE APPEARED IN PUBLIC FOR
THE VERY FIRST TIME.
AND LATER AT THE DELAWARE WAR
MEMORIAL AND OF COURSE HIS BRIEF
APPEARANCE OUTDOORS, BIDEN
HEADED RIGHT BACK TO HIS
BASEMENT WHERE HE IS
CONTINUING TO MUMBLE HIS WAY
THROUGH ONE VIRTUAL PART-TIME
CAMPAIGN PODCAST AFTER ANOTHER.
SO WHAT IS NOW STILL OFFICIALLY
DAY 72 OF BIDEN’S BASEMENT RUN.
AND IN ALL HONESTY COMMITS MORE
THAN HE CAN SEEMINGLY HANDLE.
BUT JOE BIDEN THINKS HE’S DOING
JUST FINE.
JUST LISTEN TO JOE.
>> I DON’T WANT TO GET DOWN INTO
NICKNAMES, BUT THIS IS A FELLA
WHO LOOKS LIKE HE’S HAVING
TROUBLE CONTROLLING HIS OWN
EMOTIONS.
WHAT WORRIES ME IS ALL OF THIS
STUFF ABOUT BIDEN’S HIDING.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS, IT IS
WORKING PRETTY WELL.
>> Sean: HIDING IS WORKING
GREAT.
NOW SOMEONE ON THE STAFF MIGHT
WANT TO REMIND HIM ABOUT A
COUPLE OF TRAIN WRECK INTERVIEWS
PRETTY MUCH DAILY NOW THAT GOES
ON FRIDAY.
BIDEN ACTUALLY DECLARED THAT HE
WAS GOING TO BEAT JOE BIDEN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ARE YOU PREPARED NOW TO SAY
YOU ARE GOING TO GOVERN AS A
PROGRESSIVE AND ENACT PROGRAMS
WITH SANDERS HANNA WORN AND IF
SO, WHAT DOES THAT SAY TO EITHER
MODERATE DEMOCRATS OR
DEPENDENTS OR EVEN SOME
REPUBLICANS TO SATISFY THE
PRESIDENT TRUMP?
>> I’M PREPARED TO SAY THAT I
HAVE A RECORD FOR OVER 40 YEARS,
AND THAT I’M GOING TO BEAT
JOE BIDEN.
LOOK AT MY RECORD.
>> Sean: WE WILL LET YOU
DECIDE TO.
BUT WHAT PROGRESSIVE MEANS IS
THAT MEANS NEW GREENDALE
ECONOMI DEAT FO AMERICA.
AND THAT’S NOT HYPERBOLE AT THIS
POINT, HE’S DOING A PRETTY
GOOD JOB OF BEATING HIMSELF AND
ALSO ON FRIDAY, HE HAD ANOTHER
DISASTROUS INTERVIEW WITH RADIO
HOST CHARLAMAGNE AND IT WAS SO
BAD THAT ONE BITE AND STAFFER
ACTUALLY TRIED TO INTERJECT IN
ORDER TO PREVENT HIS EVER
CONFUSED, COMPOUNDED BOSS OF
HAVING TO ANSWER ANY MORE
QUESTIONS.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> ELECT PEOPLE SAVED YOUR LIFE
IN THE PRIMARY.
ONE IS A BLACK WOMAN RUNNING
MATE.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THIS?
>> WHAT I SAY TO THAT IS I’M NOT
ACKNOWLEDGING ANYONE BEING
CONSIDERED, BUT I GUARANTEE
THERE ARE MULTIPLE, BLACK WOMEN
BEING CONSIDERED.
MULTIPLE.
>> THAT IS REALLY OUR TIME.
I APOLOGIZE I APOLOGIZE.
>> YOU CAN’T DO THAT TO BLACK
MEDIA.
YOU CAN’T DO THAT TO WHITE MEDIA
AND BLACK MEDIA BECAUSE MY WIFE
HAS TO GO ON AT 6:00.
>> OKAY.
>> I’M IN TROUBLE.
>> Sean: I’M IN TROUBLE.
MOMENTS AFTER THAT EXCHANGE,
BIDEN TOLD THE SAME HOST, YOU
AIN’T BLACK IF YOU DON’T SUPPORT
HIM IN THE ELECTION.
WHAT?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IT’S A LONG WAY UNTIL
NOVEMBER.
WE HAVE MORE QUESTIONS.
>> YOU HAVE MORE QUESTIONS.
IF YOU HAVE A PROBLEM FIGURING
OUT IF YOU ARE FOR ME OR TRUMP,
THEN YOU AIN’T BLACK.
HE WENT OKAY, BIDEN IS FACING A
PREDICTABLE WAVE OF CRITICISM
ONE DAY AFTER THE INTERVIEW,
CHARLAMAGNE SAID BIDEN IS AN
INTRICATE PART OF THE SYSTEM
THAT NEEDS TO BE DISMANTLED.
THE FOUNDER OF BET CALLED ON
BIDEN TO APOLOGIZE TO EVERY
BLACK PERSON HE MEETS THROUGHOUT
HIS CAMPAIGN.
EVEN A PROMINENT BIDEN SUPPORTER
JAMES CLYBOURN WHO BAILED HIM
OUT OF -- WAS CLEARLY TAKEN
BACK.
>> HI, FRANCE, IN THIS INSTANCE,
JOE
DID NOT DO AS WELL AS I HAD
HOPE.
HE RESPONDED TO, BUT I WILL SAY
THIS.
I GO ABOUT MY BUSINESS EVERY DAY
DAY.
AND WILL CARRY JOE BIDEN TO THE
ALTERNATIVE, NOT THE ALMIGHTY.
>> Sean: FIGHT AND OLD TO
ME -- ULTIMATELY HALF-HEARTED
SAID HE SHOULDN’T BE A WISE GUY
BUT WHAT HE
SAID ON THAT RADIO PROGRAM
WAS MORE THAN ONE OFF CAMPAIGN
GAP.
WE ALL KNOW THAT.
IT IS PART OF A LONG, NEVER
ENDING DISTURBING PATTERN OF
RACIAL RHETORIC, NUMBER 1977.
BIDEN WORRIED HIS CHILDREN WOULD
GROW UP IN A "RACIAL JUNGLE IF
IMMIGRATION IS NOT DONE IN AN
ORDERLY WAY."
1993 SAID THE INNER-CITY CRIME
CAUSED BY CRIME ON THE STREETS
AND PRISON SENTENCES RAMPED UP
ALL ACROSS AMERICA.
DONALD TRUMP FIX THAT, BY THE
WAY, SLIGHT OBSERVATION.
2006 HE TOLD THE CROWD YOU HAVE
TO HAVE SLIGHT INDIAN ACCENT TO
WORK AT 7-ELEVEN OR
DUNKIN’ DONUTS.
2007, HOW COULD WE FORGET WHEN
HE CALLED BARACK OBAMA THE FIRST
MAINSTREAM AFRICAN-AMERICAN WHO
IS ARTICULATE AND BRIGHT AND
CLEAN.
IT IS STORYBOOK, MAN.
HIS WORDS, NOT MINE.
HE BRAGGED HIS STATE WAS A
STATE.
THE GUY ALSO PLAYED THE RACE
CARD.
THEY WILL PUT YOU ALL BACK AND
CHAINS.
2019, HE BRAGGED ABOUT HIS WORK
WITH SEGREGATION TO GET THINGS
DONE IN THE U.S. SENATE.
THIS IS JUST THE TIP OF THE
ICEBERG.
LET’S TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE LARGEST GROWTH OF
POPULATION IS POPULATION IS
INDIAN AMERICANS.
IF YOU ARE FROM INDIA, YOU
CANNOT GO TO A 7-ELEVEN OR A
DUNKIN’ DONUTS UNLESS YOU HAVE A
SLIGHT INDIAN ACCENT.
I’M NOT JOKING.
>> WHAT KIND OF CHANCE WITH
NORTHEASTERN LIBERAL LIKE
JOE BIDEN STAND IN THE SOUTH?
>> YOU DON’T KNOW MY STATE.
MY STATE WAS A STATE, A BORDER
STATE.
MY STATE IS THE EIGHTH LARGEST
IN THE COUNTRY.
>> A MAINSTREAM AMERICA.
WHO IS ARTICULATE AND BRIGHT AND
CLEAN AND A MUSLIM GUY.
I MEAN, THAT IS STORYBOOK.
>> THEY WILL PUT YOU ALL BACK IN
CHAINS.
>> Sean: BRIGHT, ARTICULATE,
CLEAN AND IN ADDITION TO WHAT
YOU SAW, BIDEN LYING WITH HIS
ROLE IN THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT IN 1987.
HE TOLD CROWDS HE MARCHED IN A
CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT AND
PARTICIPATED IN SIT IN PROTEST.
HE WAS LATER FORCED TO ADMIT
THAT WAS A LIE.
THE PLAGIARIST HIMSELF IS WEAK
RECALL THE FIRST TIME HE RAN FOR
PRESIDENT, MORE RECENTLY
LYING ABOUT GETTING ARRESTED BY
THE APARTHEID, SOUTH AFRICAN
GOVERNMENT WHILE ON HIS WAY TO
SEE NELSON MANDELA.
BIDEN WAS NEVER ARRESTED.
AND DURING BIDENS DISASTROUS
INTERVIEW ON FRIDAY CLAIMED THE
NCAA P ENDORSED HIM EVERY TIME
HE RAN.
BUT IN A RECENT STATEMENT NAACP
SAID THEY NEVER ENDORSED
JOE BIDEN BECAUSE IT IS A
NONPARTISAN ORGANIZATION.
THE QUESTION TONIGHT WITH JUST
161 DAYS UNTIL ELECTION DAY, YOU
COME AT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
BECOME THE ULTIMATE JURY.
DOES ANYONE ACTUALLY BELIEVE
THAT THE 77-YEAR-OLD LIFELONG
POLITICIAN, DO YOU REALLY
BELIEVE HE HAS THE STAMINA TO